this year
[Music]
foreign Christian
s
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's so great to see all of you here
tonight we've got a great crowd
uh for those of you joining us online
also we extend this warm welcome and all
of our same love to you whether you're
tuning in from farther out or nearby
like Audra love you lots
for those of you who may not know me my
name is Marisa Martinez I'm not new to
the table but I am new to this
forward-facing position
in fact everything about tonight is new
this is our first ever service LED
entirely by our table team group
super exciting
right
they have been hard at work preparing to
put together a wonderful service for us
and I'm excited to see this I can't wait
to jump in
uh before we do though before we get
started I'd like to say a few words over
our little Community would you bow your
heads and pray with me
Yahweh
it is with gratitude and humility That
We Gather tonight to lean on and support
each other
to love and learn from each other
to actively nurture and live out Kingdom
on Earth
as we focus on new voices tonight we
pray you gently open our hearts and
Minds alike to truly hear their hearts
and Minds
to learn from them
to be inspired by them
may we hear you through them
may you impart your wisdom Upon Our
Youth and may the holy spirit guide them
as they lead us
may we support and nurture their hearts
in leadership today and always
we pray this in your holy name amen
all right everyone I am so glad to see
all of you here so if you will join us
in worship and stand up we're going to
start with trust in you
letting go of every single dream
I lay each one down at your feet
every moment of my wondering
never changes what you see
I tried to win this War I confess
hands are weary I need your rest
mighty warrior king of the fight
no matter what I face you're by my side
when you don't move the mountains
[Applause]
I wish I could walk through when you
don't give the answers as I Cry
I will trust I will trust I will trust
in you
truth is you know what tomorrow brings
not a day ahead you have not seen us so
when all things be my life
[Music]
I wish I could walk through when you
don't give the answers as I cry out to
you I will trust I will trust I will
trust in you
I will trust in you
foreign
[Music]
you to move when you don't part the
waters I wish I could walk through when
you don't give the answers as I cry out
to you I will trust I will trust I will
trust in you
I will trust in you
foreign
kindergarten you guys are going in that
room and then everyone else you're going
in that room
[Music]
all right and now we are going to go
ahead and transition into our prayers of
the people we're going to read the words
on the screen all together and then
we're going to leave a space where
everyone can voice people they want to
pray for situations they want to pray
for and we're just going to lift it up
to the Lord so everyone join me in these
words
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and will to conserve it we
pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
please
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and Hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
foreign
waiting for change to come
knowing the battles one
for you have never failed me yet
your promise still stands great is your
faithfulness faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence
you've never failed me yet
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Jesus You're Still Enough
keep me within your love
my heart will sing your praise again
your promise still stands great is your
faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is
great is your
faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is
oh
yesterday
I've seen you move you move the
mountains and I believe
I'll see you do it again you made a way
when there was no way and I believe
I'll see you do it again you've seen you
move
you move the mountains and I believe
I'll see you do it again
I see it do it again I've seen you move
of the mountains and I believe
I'll see you do it again you made a way
where there was no way and I believe
I'll see you do it again
[Music]
see you do it again
you do it again
you promise to stands great is your
faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence you've never failed me yet
you promised still stands great is your
faithfulness faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence
you've never failed me yes
thank you
foreign
so this next song I'm introducing and
it's called Give Me Faith
um and in the teen group we've been
doing this song A lot
um and it just means a lot to us as a
whole I think Michael has introduced it
to almost all of us and we've really
grasped onto the lyrics
um and really thought about them and I
feel like it speaks to each and every
uh not even situation but phase that
maybe you've gone through in your life
and I feel like everyone can resonate
with these lyrics but it's just like a
very special song to us that we thought
would be very appropriate to share with
you all
um during youth Sunday so yeah
[Music]
I need you
to soften my heart
and break me apart I need you
to open my eyes and see that you
use your life
oh I am
I Surrender
[Music]
Give Me Faith to trust what you say
that you're good and your love is great
I'm broken inside I give you my life
[Music]
I need you
to soften my heart and break me apart I
need you
to pierce through the dark and cleanse
every part of me
all I am
I
surrendered
Give Me Faith to trust what you say
they are good your love is great
I'm broken inside I give you my life
I may be weak your spirit's strong in me
my flesh May Fail
my God you'll never win
I may be weak
your spirit's strong in me my flesh may
fail my God you never will give me Faith
to trust what you say
we are good your life is great
I'm broken inside I give you my life
is yours
is your need faith you trust what you
say
you're good
again I may be weak
your spirit's strong in me my flesh May
Fail
my God you never will I'm baby weak
your spirit is strong in me
My Flesh May
be weak
your spirit is
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
dear God thank you so much for letting
us all gather here today thank you for
giving us the strength to move on no
matter what life throws in US
um thank you that everybody gets to
enjoy and come together on this great
day that we celebrate your name amen
[Music]
all right
thank you guys so much for aren't they
cool aren't they great
[Music]
I was getting very emotional up here
I'm so proud of them
um I really am this is like I don't know
I told them like it's a big deal to me
not just because it's such a huge deal
that they're on the stage but it's a big
deal to me because I want I want to
create a community where our teens are
part of it and where our kids are
Incorporated and not just behind walls
all the time and this is part of our
heart when we started the table it was
part of my heart to see us learn to let
them lead us every once in a while and
learn from them and so tonight is like
our first big I mean we've been doing
Tiny Steps you know but I feel like this
is like our first big step to to say
like yes we are committed to this as a
community as a body not just you know
certain individuals are like yeah cool
we like teenagers
but as a community we want their voice
in the mix you know so that's what
tonight is all about so I hope you were
greeted by the cutest of all people out
by the door and I hope it just
transitions you all the way through the
service
um so I wanted to um give you a little
bit of just some background and info on
what we've been talking about in youth
over the past year and then I want to
hand off the mic and let you hear
actually from a couple of our teams
about their you know let them share a
little bit of their own Journeys with
you
um but just to preface y'all like
exactly one year ago in January we had
our first teen Meetup Night Like
official meeting
um right here in this room after the
service and we've continued on Sunday
nights after the service this is where
we meet and
um it's been really really amazing but
what I could not have anticipated was
having the most
I'm just gonna censor myself we have a
really amazing youth team
you fill in the blank there they are
that they are they are the best team I
could have ever ever asked for of
leadership and um
I just want to name them really fast I'm
just going to admit y'all saw Michael
but Michael could you stand up and Abby
could you stand up and Marissa could you
stand up
laughs
I love them
so much so much and I'm so grateful for
their leadership y'all because some of
them y'all can sit down now but some of
them
regularly are getting here like at two
or three to start set up and help with
other things and then staying after
service till like eight o'clock well we
finish at eight
hopefully we leave the building by nine
but anyways I mean it's a long day for
them so I just had to take a minute to
say like they're incredible but not just
because of the time they give they are
the most high quality people I have ever
been on a youth team with and I have
been on youth teams before at other
churches and I'm telling you there this
is the phrase for those of you who are
like oh bummer I like real sermons where
I can like take notes and really get
into it here's your quote for the night
you can write it down and say that you
took a note okay but this is the best
way I could ever describe this team and
I'm gonna steal it from a good dear
friend of mine Juanita Johnson who
helped us start this community and one
of the things she taught me was Maggie
you do not need the veneer of perfection
when you have authentic love
and we
talked about that as a team when we
started like listen we're not here to
pretend like we have some awesome youth
program at the table we're a very small
Church all of us have day jobs
we don't you know what I mean we it was
like a very Loaves and Fishes thing like
okay God we do have a heart for teens
though and we want to make a place for
them and we have this much to give like
it's this tiny it's Sunday nights after
church is that enough but I really
really they have authentic love that I
I've never ever gotten to be on a team
with people like that that is so sincere
and so high quality I just anyways so I
love them and we
um oh like divide up the
responsibilities each week of bringing
food to these teenagers because really I
think that's if we could leave after
eating food and they're like great we
loved it thanks for the food
um but bringing food and we play games
together and we
um Michael oftentimes is leading Us in
worship and that last song that we did
he introduced us to that and that's just
been our go-to for months
um but um and then
um often times I will volunteer to help
lead our discussion or scriptures and
sometimes the other adult leaders to do
too as well but um we've kind of bounced
around on topics we we started out by
just talking about different passages of
scripture and looking at them and seeing
how they relate to our lives or you know
what do we maybe have to learn from this
or can we relate to it at all and
um I feel like those early months at the
beginning we were all just kind of like
figuring out how to be together and then
um coming into the summer we started
looking into the Psalms and we started
reading Psalms and talking about this
theme of looking up at the time just
right before like at the end of the Fall
I happened to watch that movie don't
look up have any of you seen it with
Leonardo DiCaprio
and then I was reading Psalms and I was
like oh my gosh you know what the theme
of Psalms is look up keep looking up
look up again and the Psalms is the most
amazing book of the Bible that is so raw
and so real but the thing about it
that's amazing is I feel like this
generation they're good at real like
they are not big fakers they don't are
they're not impressed by people faking
they don't like it at all and they can
sniff it out and tell you like
immediately like that's so fake I'm not
even I'm not into it they hate you know
what I mean they hate that but um the
flip side though is when you get into
the Psalms you can't just have raw and
real all the time there's no depth there
just honesty by itself is not enough but
if you take your honesty and then you
turn it and look up and say I also know
that what I'm experiencing isn't the
whole story my life is one little corner
of this really huge massive universe and
there's
other truth out there as well as mine so
mine is true and I need to be honest I
need to be real and raw before God but I
also need to take this raw real
experience and look up and put it in
context of this larger truth this larger
reality of God and and the cosmos and
you know what I mean let's be rooted and
grounded in something bigger than
ourselves
um so that's that was sort of our theme
for the summer and then coming into the
fall I just
we started looking at some scriptures
because we started
um we started with like Advent season
and all of that and talking about
um Isaiah and looking at who the Messiah
was going to be and what was he like and
there was this one guiding question that
I would always ask them to keep in the
back of their minds when reading
scripture anybody want to just volunteer
a hand look Eden knows what is the
question how does this uh passage like
change your context of like who God is
or like inform your context of who God a
plus Eden
a plus
we just kept talking about when you read
scriptures and when you read about Jesus
be asking the question how does this
inform my concept of who God is and that
was kind of what we spent our time on
during the fall
but
Marissa do you mind sticking your head
in there and grabbing I think I left my
person there which has my phone in it
which has the quotes that I wanted to
read I'm pretty sure
um that Black Backpack leather purse
but as of recently we transitioned to
talking about faith and what is Faith
and um I want I want to read these
because I actually started jotting down
notes during some of our times together
as a group the red phone is it in there
ah you're awesome thank you
um
but
so organized here guys
yeah here we go
um
we talked about the fact that the word
faith is used in so many contexts in our
culture and it can be used in so many
ways so many different parts of speech
faith can be like a noun almost the same
way you talk about a house we talk about
faith like oh what faith did you grow up
in oh what faith you know did you come
from like it's a place or you know a
thing or an object that you could like
find or lose where did you find your
faith when did you find your faith you
know what I mean have you lost your
faith and um oftentimes it operates like
that other times it operates like an
adjective like describing a person or
like an attribute of theirs like oh my
gosh she has such strong faith oh my
gosh they are so faithful you know like
these this word faith is one that we
hear a lot but it's kind of used in so
many different ways that it can become a
very abstract Concept in our lives and
um I asked the teenagers well the other
one it can be used as a verb right and
faith is something that you're acting
out and walking out so I asked him like
what do you think what what do you think
faith is is it a noun is it a verb what
what is it
um
so I wanted to read some of their words
to you
um
this one came from Jeremiah because
Jeremiah is our resident theologian
sitting right here in front of you if
you asked Jeremiah question he will find
the correct answer to the question
immediately there's no such thing as
like Jeremiah what do you think he's
like oh no I'll tell you actually what
is true
there's no opinions here there's only
facts so he did he looked it up and he
was like um faith is a promise and
um it is oftentimes also called a
promise to believe do you remember that
what was that oh my do not do that sorry
I freaked him out I want them to hear
what you were saying
the dictionary of biblical languages and
in Greek that's what the word means not
in English it's different in English
there we go see I mean resident
Theologian so
um so we started there
um but then we got into these other
discussions or it kind of led us into
looking into some scriptures and um
someone said
I would say faith is a verb because it's
often at times like when I'm laying in
my bed alone at night that I start to
think about God and whether I even know
God or understand him at all
but faith is what I'm doing when I'm
trying
faith is my best attempt at
understanding a relationship with Jesus
isn't that so beautiful I was like can
you say all of that again while I write
that down
someone said I would say that Faith
involves more trust than it does belief
trusting is harder than believing
trusting has to do with relenting and
that's where true Faith happens
someone else said
maybe faith is trans
it appears like a noun on the surface
but underneath it demands an action a
call to action
[Applause]
said that I don't know
and then one of my favorites I'd say
faith is like friendship the title means
nothing it's all about the follow
through
isn't that good
see y'all should be taking notes on this
um the last one and and JJ helped us
with this scripture was we studied James
chapter two what good is it my brothers
and sisters if someone claims to have
faith but has no Deeds can such Faith
save them
in the same way Faith by itself if it is
not accompanied by action is dead as the
body without the spirit is dead so faith
without Deeds is dead
I did leave a lot of scriptures out
there
is that I'm just thinking JJ's probably
like actually you just skipped over like
eight sentences I'm paraphrasing for
time but that is like that is like the
meat of what's happening on Sunday
nights after youth and I just love it so
much and I wanted to give
um Noel and Eden had both volunteered to
share a little bit of Their Own Story so
I wanted to ask them to come up if you
guys would welcome them please
okay
have a seat have a seat
I'm gonna borrow this green mic
so Noel can have this one Red's my
favorite
yes right me and you both okay
so
um I asked Noelle and Eden if I could
um just have them share a little bit of
their own Journeys but to get to make it
a little bit easier
to know where to start I sent them some
questions
and um
let me go to the right note here guys
um I'm going to start with Eden
oh okay Eden can you tell us what grade
you're in
um I'm in 11th grade
and what high school are you at Allen
High School guys it's it's pretty cool
the Junior at Allen High and
um
so the question that Eden was like yeah
I think that's that would be an easy one
for me to talk about was how does your
walk with Christ today look different
than it did in earlier years how has it
changed or how has it taken on new
meaning
okay so I feel like to fully answer this
question you kind of have to
know what my faith meant before
um and so let's travel a little bit back
to when I was born and raised and
baptized in the church
and I forget I should have asked my
parents what kind of church but it
wasn't non-denominational but later we
did move to a non-denominational church
and like my toddler years
and 11 or 12 years after we moved to
that church
um
it we moved to a new building because of
the demanding space we were growing too
much
um and then
suddenly we couldn't make that space
work
um we were losing money rapidly and we
eventually had to close the church and
that was one of the first times that
like I
really felt like so disconnected from
God like I I just didn't understand and
didn't make a lot of sense and
I still like I was lost from church but
I don't think like my faith was like
displaced
um I don't think my faith went with it I
still had like the Bible stories from
when I was a kid and you know like
that's still foundational faith that
um I think was really key in that and
then
um
that was all good and well until about
sixth grade
um I have a distinct memory of being in
the shower and just thinking like
oh no I like girls and it was like this
it wasn't this oh freeing experience it
was oh no what am I going to do you know
where do I even go and I had so many
questions and so little resources and
people to talk to and I didn't even
think being queer and being a part of
the church was an option like that had
never that would never have come to mind
for me and I just knew so deeply
that
I knew who I liked and I didn't
I said that I was saved at that point
but I don't really feel like I had a
great relationship with Jesus
um because I was just like always raised
and I don't feel like there was a
distinct like now this is my life to
Jesus like I feel like it was just
always kind of like that
um and so
during covid
um I well first I came out as a lesbian
and then during covid I
really really found my faith like I
got so many theological books some that
I have never read
um but but they're sitting there just to
prove it to you guys
um no but they're it's really great I
think I should loan some to JJ
um anyway so I really really found my
faith and
um I knew that these two things I
couldn't
I couldn't
give away anything I couldn't compromise
um and this is when I found out about
like I started
um
I was still struggling with that I
started doing devotionals online I have
an Instagram page still I haven't posted
in it in a month because of the musical
but
it's it's there and I'm going to get to
it I promise
um but I had just posted like quick
devotionals on it like 10 minutes or so
and it really like furthered my faith in
God and I wasn't doing it just to spread
the word to other people I was also
doing it for my own faith because it was
such a learning experience and I feel
like
I've been told I'm a good speaker so I
feel like
I can relay a lot to like
a teen level I guess
um and so
when I started my devotional page
um
I
got I was out at this point and I got an
Instagram DM
um
it was
from someone that I had never talked to
I never asked them any questions
never asked for their opinion
and they just gave gave it to me that
you can't be doing this like this isn't
right what you're doing is wrong and you
can't like and you should know that it's
wrong you like
just basically that like
it was no ambiguity like they were being
very direct and very
like
oh this should like you should already
know this like what you're doing is
wrong and it was so extremely hurtful to
me that someone I had never talked to
could care so much
um about what I'm doing with my life to
the point where they reach out to me
um and that had really broken a barrier
between
me and whatever else that I really
thought was out there trying to get at
me trying to make me Feud on these two
sides like it really became real in that
moment and so
um
she
made me
question myself so much more and then I
found
um one of my good friends Molly Bohm and
I don't know if that's how you pronounce
her last name I've never asked
um but she's she's a pastor at
um a McKinney
I'm not gonna say what denomination I
know but it is like one of the older
Hymnal denominations and although it
wasn't for me it was uh the first queer
firming church that I had ever seen and
this was during covet still so I
literally
I sent in an email saying like could we
talk like
and so we called up and I just I was
like explain to me
theologically why I'm not in the wrong
like and she basically told me
she she did explain to me and then at
the end she said you know you can go
your whole life shoving this away and
you can keep doing this
um but it's never going to change and
trust me I've talked to so many people
who have done that and it hasn't changed
who they are and that has really stuck
with me
um and then
I came out
well not really
um but I realized I'm trans and it was a
slow transition to where I am as he him
today
um but I feel like so much better about
my queerness and my transness and my
faith and like I feel so rooted in both
that it's not even a question to me
anymore like if I'm valid doing what I
am I'm in being who I am and
people say
so many things about
queer people and trans people from all
sides and from all sides Christian
people and it felt for a very long time
like a tug of war
and like
the queer people were against the
Christians and the Christians were
against the queer people and I found a
place where it's not like that and that
has been one of the most
you know beautiful things that so I
would just like to thank you all for
making this happen because this has been
a space
that has really founded my faith
um and has been really integral in my
journey
um and then in closing I just I want to
talk a little bit about
um
how I feel my journey is to be a light
for
specifically queer people but also
Christians to just open up their mind
just a little bit more and think that
like
more things can be possible than what
they really perceive and just to be like
a leader and I've gotten so many people
um text me because I
um will post about my faith quite often
on Instagram and just text me like I had
no idea that that you could be both like
like genuinely shocked and I feel like
it's so normalized in this space that
sometimes we forget like
people are genuinely like I've never met
another person like this like it is it's
one of the most amazing things that I
can do for other people is open that
door and maybe even if it's not changing
people's minds it's planting a seed a
seed of Doubt a seed of Faith whatever
it is that really begins to show in
people and
um I promise I'm just a little bit
longer but I had a few more scriptures
that I remember reading when I was going
through this whole transition and
um really
that really stuck with me
um and this is
uh Isaiah 43 1 and it says do not fear
for I have redeemed you I called you by
your name you are mine
then there's another one it's Galatians
3 20 28 and I I love this one there's
neither Jew nor Gentile another slave
nor free nor is there male and female
for you are all one in Jesus Christ and
I remember using this in a talk about I
actually did a devotional a little bit
back called everyone has a place at the
table
um
yeah I think it even before I knew this
church existed kind of foreshadowing a
little bit I guess
um but
and I had people from that be like
I've never heard that like I belong you
know especially in a Christian context
um and so
and then I brought in another scripture
about
um that the human body has many parts
but many parts make up the whole body so
it is with the body of Christ some of us
are Jews some are Gentiles some are
slaves and some are free but we have all
been baptized into one body by one
spirit and we all share the same spirit
this is First Corinthians 12 12 through
13. and
um
I feel like without the queer people in
the church we have lost the body of
Christ
and
um yeah that's that's where I think I'm
going to leave it um but thank you all
for making this happen
and just being a part of this
really means a lot
so good eating
thank you
thank you thank you
okay
what's your name
I'm Noelle
I'm a senior at Wiley High and this will
like technically be my last year on
youth which is so sad so uh that's why I
was like okay well this is going to be
the only youth Sunday that I can really
be a part of so like I gotta jump all in
I gotta do it all right something that's
why you know yeah yes I did tell Noelle
I was like listen we need to take
advantage of every opportunity we have
together because this is coming close to
an end
foreign
but I did I wanted you guys to hear from
Noelle
um because it feels
it does feel extremely fitting to have
her up here
first team when I was like I want to do
teen Ministry and Noel was like all in
like yeah let's do it let's do it let's
start it let's go and um and she's been
with me from the beginning
okay so
um Noel yeah
how is your faith informing your daily
life your future choices your
relationships or responsibilities like
what impact does it have on your daily
life and with that you can share maybe
any challenges that it presented
presents as well so yeah so in the minor
household we really like to yeah
um
we really like Enneagram you know just
in general there's a lot of people at
the table who like Enneagram
um but anyways so this is probably the
easiest way for me to just explain like
my mental like I don't know how to
explain the way I think so I'm like a
very very strong three and that
basically means that like I get
like my joy and I'm kind of like calmed
down whenever I'm checking off lists I'm
completing tasks and for me it's hard
because it's like
when that's absent when there's nothing
to do like where is
like where is me like who am I and uh
like what am I doing I just feel like
okay I'm kind of empty like where's
where's the source of anything and
another thing kind of on top of that is
along with those like lists and
everything
um
whenever something is not going to plan
the way it is in my head it is really
really really hard for me to accept
anything different
so one of the biggest things and this is
a way that faith has challenged me but
in a good way because there's times
where I need to and like you know my mom
will remind me of this or whoever will
remind me of this yeah so yeah go Karen
go care
um well remind me like
like you know okay so your plan it's not
exactly like what you thought it was
going to be that opens up the space for
new opportunities to come into my life
new things that I wouldn't have planned
out for myself because obviously every
plan that I am having is strictly my
routine my opinion whatever but that's
being so close-minded because I'm not
opening up the space for New
Perspectives New Opportunities and again
that's what I'm saying that's how faith
has challenged me but in a good way
because I'm able to kind of leave
sometimes I just have to remind myself
like leave it open and we all remind
ourselves sometimes like we are not in
control of the things that happen in our
lives like yes we can control the way we
respond but a lot of the difficulties
that we face like and all you know
achievements as well normally those
aren't going exactly how you planned and
things that are difficulties in my life
mainly have led to higher points and
points where I learn more about myself
where I'm able to kind of
you know interact with more people
um and that's all because sometimes you
just have to let go and have faith and
that's something I've struggled with and
it's something like as I've grown and
matured
um it's like one of the biggest things
that I realize about myself is like I'm
just such a a planner and like
very very like bad anxiety you know like
that's just how I am and everything
needs to be perfect and I need to please
everyone but that's not that's not the
case you just leave it open for things
to come to you
um
then again that just opens the door for
people to walk into your life that you
never thought would walk into your life
um opportunities and achievements
there's been several times in my life
where like there's been a really really
low spot but that has led me to a higher
place that I didn't think I would be at
and led me to be more comfortable in
everything and also just having faith
that doing things for yourself
even if that means you're not pleasing
everyone around you yeah that's what
could be better for you in the long run
so that's kind of how faith has like
challenged me but in a good way just to
kind of be like hey like this is not all
about what you think that your life
should like obviously we all have goals
but it's like you know leave it open and
have some faith and know that things
will turn out
you know the alternate Okay so
yeah sounds like a lot of identity work
there Noel for sure for sure yeah and it
reminds me of the quote that I shared
earlier with the student who said
uh Faith what they say is less like
believing and more like trusting
trust involves relenting and allowing
things to happen you have to give up you
know give up stuff to get stuff
sometimes yeah
so good
are you good yeah do you have anything
else before we
send it off or I didn't know if you were
separating into two different questions
or kind of answering all I want to leave
room for Jeremiah to share okay so I'm
totally great with handing it over guys
can you please give them a hand
thank you
[Applause]
um if yeah if you guys want to move the
stools out of the way thank you Noelle
and Eden very much for your transparency
vulnerability authenticity I just really
appreciate it
and um you guys can be praying for them
I mean this is like
I feel like teenage years are hard
period no matter what decade you live in
but each one feels like we have new
challenges you know that are surfacing
every generation so okay they're getting
restless it's time for us to transition
to communion
so I wanted to ask Jeremiah Parker he
has volunteered to do our Celtic call to
the table so Michael if you don't mind
um just giving us some background music
and Jeremiah is going to lead us in that
and then we have two of our teens August
runnels and Matthew Miner who will be
serving you communion tonight so the
instructions will be up on the screen
um once Jeremiah finishes you guys can
go ahead and become begin uh lining up
here and we do have a gluten-free bread
but also
um there is I believe a white uh wine
option or grape juice oh the white is
the grape juice let's be clear the white
is the grape juice the purple
involves alcohol
okay Jeremiah I'm gonna hand it over to
you
this is the church
not at the table but of the Lord and it
is made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more
so you have much faith and you have
little
come you have been here often and you
have not been here long you have tried
to follow and you who have failed
come for it is the Lord himself who
invites you it is his will that everyone
who wants to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
foreign
never changes why you see I try to win
this War I confess
my hands are weary I need your rest
mighty warrior king of the fight
no matter what I face you by my side
when you don't move the mountains
[Applause]
I Cry I cry out to you I will trust I
will trust I will trust in you
truth is
[Music]
I want what you want Lord and nothing
less when you don't move
[Music]
will trust in you
you are my strength and comfort you are
my steady
hands
are always higher your plans are always
good there's not a place where I'll go
you've not already
[Music]
you should
move when you don't part the waters I
wish I could walk through when you don't
give the answers as I cry out to you I
will trust I will trust I will trust in
you
I will trust in you
[Music]
hello at the table we have a tradition
of a parting message
so if you feel so inclined you can raise
and open your hands to take this message
or whatever you're comfortable with you
can sit whatever you feel like
you are a child of God you are a child
of God this is true on your best days
and these two on your worst days too so
as you go into your upcoming week with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and all the crazy little things in
between go with the promise that you are
loved you are worthy you are accepted
just as you are and go filled with God's
Holy Spirit and the desire to extend
these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love with everyone you
come in contact with
have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]